ciao sono i miliari nel futuro quello
che è successo che questa settimana
tutta quanta la mia famiglia in maniera
scaglionata sia un pochino rivista tocca
a noi oddio è lo so sick wakata l'avevo
detto che esce sono divise fermano
glielo dimostra come posso metodi altro
ma come se ti metti dietro le regole
sono che testa davanti a chi dietro
l'altra puramente quarto i vetri dopo
praticamente quasi due mesi di
solitudine totale visto che ho passato
una 40ina senza nessuno finalmente il
governo mi ha permesso ci ha permesso di
poter iniziare sempre stando molto
attenti a rivedere le persone ed
eversione che sono venuti a trovarmi
sono state gianmarco enrico a
[Musica]
ma chi cioè qui non so dire quale sia la
cosa più strana nel rivedere qualcuno al
quale molto bene a prenderti conto di
quanto è mancato e nel contenuto secondi
per tornano odiarli a non sopportarlo
perché comunque dopo un po di polipo
fuori ben scolpiti sequel maiale rino
arriva se queste cose se i teletubbies
in uk e non ci credo no vabbè tanto
criticato il tuo fratello
mamma mia senti che puzza c'è una cappa
qui dentro del tuo blog di gas
io sentivo corsa di bruciato luigi
marchegiani cimentato le direttive
seguito tutta la vita profumo alla
lettera quali è buonissimo tra google e
il mio zaino c'è il computer dentro
questa fase due senza la fase uno è lo
store andato tutto bene
mai detto 20 minuti ero lasciato a 20
minuti
senza tutto sia la gianmarco diciamo
adesso fumo così come sono andato in
cucina
una cappa sembra un incendio o aperto
carbonizzato perché sono il capo cioè a
mangiarle fischiava bibi non dire niente
tutto sembrava un incendio me lo sono
dimenticato ragazzi questo è pazzesco io
pensavo che ci volesse molto più tempo
te l'ho detto ma venti minuti si anche
40 anche uno ora me lo devi dire anche i
dieci minuti a crudo da vinci momento vi
mettete in forno al massimo scusa ma non
è ke te poter tira indietro era perfetto
ma ne vanno la corteccia della morte c'e
infatti ci mangiamo sul culo e io ne so
qualcosa che è successo
questa casa stavano dormendo nel perché
la natura fa prendendo possesso di ciò
che è suo
userò questo per combattere i cinghiali
e dove questa l'angolo
si prevede che lo sono anche gli
ambientalisti perché io mi sento male
vai lacerano il continuo a non andarci
con questo dopo gianmarco enrico è
arrivato il momento di la linea è
finalmente ha portato una delle cose che
durante fisico la comit mi è stata più
richiesta in assoluto è stato un piccolo
cadeau e che ho rivisto molto piacere
anche se sembrava che ha ucciso con armi
fosse mischiata buongiorno che da
bandita si torna al lavoro va a ravviso
un problema essenziale ed enorme il
problema nello specifico il seguente non
sottolineare quei tacchi tirannosauro
[Musica]
chi sarà mai
scheda potresti essere chiunque in
realtà abbiamo leggermente spiano la
mentre sale la linea lavigne e la sua
consegna della linea da passarella
lavinia no l'altra leva la viglia
no perché con tutti
è un contadino che cade sempre in piedi
il tappetino carolina contro un ci
vediamo poi vi abbraccio così tipo
dai braccio facendo sentire l'altro polo
dopo grande erodere attiviamo prima si
chiama oggi posto tutti stamattina sono
uniti gemme harry a dire degli ultimi
che comunque di stampare riprendendo con
quello una cosa non si crede più le
capsule shaun sono le cucina grazie ci
hanno mandato in nero cantò aver finito
fisico ancora piccolo inoltre allenare
questo qui sarà il mio fidato compagno
di viaggio
devi continuare ad allenare paraga veri
continuate
se non sbaglio poi gianmarco se n'è
andato da nonna mi ha fatto anche lui
visita stiamo per girare un video si
servono delle luci che sono dentro quel
detto quello di cappuccino esatto però
il problema qual è che con figli doveva
covi della maniglia è venuta meno e non
si può più aprire la porta non sappiamo
quindi come fa a prendere le luci adesso
il nostro scopo è aprire la porta anche
forzando la irrompendo casa in genere ho
visto fare in alcuni video quelle robe
con la tessera che la infili della porta
dietro la serratura e magicamente si
apre fortunatamente c'è questa tessera
che è scaduta nel 2010 e continua a
utilizzare tutto ora però tralasciando
questo troviamo il fatto è che non entra
proprio quando ad essere cioè non c'è
uno spazio forse qui e andando giuliano
tutorial per il gruppo di un
appartamento sì sì ma no
ecco bravissima scusa ma tu hai fatto
questo tra ma spirano è rimasto il cast
confessa dove nella porta ce l'hai pensa
più di scaturita 15
di nascosto questo volantino di
guglielmo che tanto palco lo sa che
esiste quindi figurati cosa vada bene
pare che buona questa collezione degli
amici questo incastrata ormai siamo
fregati
quindi che questa buona parata purtroppo
forse sportivo fuori bravo
forse abbiamo trovato una soluzione al
quale lavora ispessire è un elastico
quello sì ma non è quello che è successo
ho provato a chi disastro è successo a
parma si è fatto ai tappato il buco
persi sono scomparsi stilista mamma mia
che disastro corrotto non è questo
massimo che sto cercando per quest anno
tematico non a quelli di plastica tipo
fionda siamo dentro
oddio siamo dentro mai mani siamo dentro
possiamo fare le cose
si parte dei presenti impazziscono buca
la sala più grande maggioranza ne
potrebbe fungere da maniglia se non la
possiamo troppo comodo pagana con la
coppa da così sarà rompe 6 lui può
provare a comunale per la spalla di una
gamba ma chi se ma arrivati a toccare
potenza suggeriamo una chiara puoi
girare come porci che la ragazza geniale
così botti questa storica perfetto un
aggeggio stupendo il tappetino che ci
deve arrivato con tassi che sono
arrivato io e si va perché lui non ce la
sentivamo di forzare la rai che cos'è
questo è un apparecchio dove si mette
male come questo ragazzi ma che penso è
stato fatto ora prendiamo le luci e il
rigo è andato a visitare jean marc è
tutta quanta la sua famiglia congiunto
che si dice è venuto in monopattino
infine la vigna non trovare
a dividerla e dire che le voglio bene ma
soprattutto spero che mi aprano tipo
ovidio sole o il paradisiaca le porte di
roma questo è l'originale
fatto sta che ci siamo incontrati tutti
quanti ed è stato molto bello sia perché
mi mancava tantissimo vedere e
abbracciare nè famiglia ma la cosa che
mi ha fatto più strano in realtà quanto
questo periodo personalmente garante non
mi abbia fatto accettare e apprezzare la
mia solitudine mi piace tantissimo
vedere le persone ma mi piace stare da
solo ho sempre pensato di essere un lupo
solitario per la vita mi ha spinto a
chiedere l'opposto il segno di verdi
realtà bisogno di stare in mezzo alla
gente per caricarmi questa ora antenne
mi ha insegnato che in realtà io da solo
sto da dio vi voglio bene è un sacco di
cose che posso fare per me che sia le
armi che sia a mangiare bene scrivere
creare in generale e più faccio queste
cose più sto bene in mezzo alle persone
ed essermi scoperto non più il prodotto
del mio passato ma essermi reso conto di
poter lavorare sul mio presente e ha
dato una carica e mi ha messo un buon
umore che da settimane continuano andare
avanti sono sincero non lo credo
possibile questo è lo spirito col quale
voglio ricominciare anche a lavorare con
i ragazzi fare per stare bene e stare
bene e quindi fare questo più o meno il
succo magari dove visto depresso ma cosa
positiva è che so che sono momenti che
quello che non di confronti di me stesso
un rapporto così come se mangi male puoi
mettere su peso se ti alleni bene poi
perde può restare più in forma così se
ti tratti male poi sprofondare in un
rapporto sbagliato con te stesso anche
se fa il contrario puoi fare e vivere
molto più sereno la prossima settimana
con un nuovo logo
e il prossimo episodio libero era un
piccolo trucchetto per riconoscere delle
uova sode